Scusa ma le crocchette per i cani le
possono mangiare anche i canarini No
così risparmio prendo un pacco unico sia
per Titti che per Lilly Mi scusi questa
pettorina secondo lei sta al mio cane è
un incrocio tra una lana e un chihuahua
lavora in un negozio di animali dovrebbe
saperlo quanto è grande sento Avete mica
dei giocattoli che non fanno rumore no
le palline rotolano mi danno fastidio
immensi io soffro di emicranias o dei
peluche no i peluche mi lascia i
pezzettini in giro no eh qualcosa che
non rotoli che non sia un peluche che
non faccia rumore che non sia una
pallina Madò Che bello quel gioco €25 un
gioco americano Minchia ma vero era
meglio che non giocava se ti aiuto ci
rimane fa ho comprato due pesci rossi in
questo negozio Sì per mio figlio non gli
volevo prendere mai esistito Insomma
aspetta due giorni che sono a galla e
dormo non so cosa stanno facendo il
bambino mi chiede non so cosa dire Ah
sono morti ah eh Dove li butto le
indifferenziato nell'umido eh
gentilmente mi mettete le pillole
tranquillizzanti non dorme agitato
Guarda non sapevo che fare come come
glielo do invece in mezzo ai croccantini
Ma in che senso scusi ma sono per mio
marito le pillole Ma qual è
ma questa non è la farmacia Santo
Stefano